canapé pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
elle porte sur l'état des négociations
européennes concernant l'hydrogène
bacarbonne celle-ci patine pour le
moment puisque le trilogue prévu hier
pour examiner la directive énergies
renouvelable a été annulée et reporté au
6 mars ce texte fixe des objectifs
ambitieux d'emploi de l'hydrogène dans
l'industrie ce dont on peut se réjouir
mais il prévoit que cette hydrogène
devrait être produit à partir
d'électricité renouvelable sans dire un
mot de l'électricité produite à partir
d'énergie nucléaire or si nous ne
pouvons pas utiliser nos réacteurs
nucléaires pour produire de l'hydrogène
la France va avoir beaucoup de mal
les objectifs européens l'Union
européenne avait déjà tenté sans succès
d'exclure le nucléaire de la taxonomie
prohibé l'hydrogène bacarbonne permet
toujours de l'attaquer indirectement
madame la ministre vous avez vivement
réagi en qualifiant cette exclusion de
climaticides et absurde nous ne pouvons
que vous en féliciter car le nucléaire
et l'énergie la moins carbonée dont nous
disposons je note par ailleurs que la
France est loin d'être le seul État
membre frustré par le contenu actuel du
texte aussi je voudrais savoir comment
se présente les négociations sur ce
sujet enfin si la France n'obtient pas
gain de cause serez-vous prêtes à
bloquer la directive énergies
renouvelable pour défendre notre filière
nucléaire et hydrogène je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
de la transition énergétique madame
panier René
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Sempé je l'affirme
nettement les négociations sur la
directive énergie renouvelable red 3 ne
prennent pas une tournure satisfaisante
sur la question de l'hydrogène et je
veux rappeler que l'engagement de la
France sur la question des énergies
renouvelables et sans ambiguïté c'est le
président de la République qui a poussé
le Green Deal en décembre 2021 c'est moi
qui présidais le Conseil énergie le
conseiller environnement qui a adopté le
paquet climat européen qui fait une
large place aux énergies renouvelables
et c'est vous qui avez adopté hier à une
très large majorité un projet
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables mais je suis d'accord avec
vous il ne faut pas se tromper de combat
notre combat c'est la décarbonation
c'est la défaussiliation et compte tenu
de l'ambition de ce combat nous devons
utiliser tous les leviers à notre
disposition tous les leviers c'est
reconnaître aujourd'hui que le nucléaire
est énergie qui émet moins de carbone
que l'énergie éolienne et que l'énergie
photovoltaïque et c'est pour ça
qu'empêcher l'utilisation du nucléaire
est effectivement je le redis une
position climaticide alors vous le savez
les discussions à Bruxelles risque de
conduire à des objectifs d'énergie
renouvelables qui ne tient pas compte de
cette réalité des tamandre nous sommes 9
aujourd'hui qui ont décarboné une partie
de leur énergie grâce au nucléaire il
n'est plus question de confondre les
moyens à savoir les énergies
renouvelables avec l'objectif final la
décarbonation la défaussénalisation nous
avons signé ces dernières semaines deux
accords avec d'une part l'Allemagne et
d'autre part l'Espagne qui reconnaissent
le rôle que peut jouer l'hydrogène
nucléaire de notre politique climatique
j'attends de ces deux partenaires qu'ils
respectent leur engagement et soyez sûr
que je ne laisserai pas adopter un texte
contraire à l'intérêt des Européens à
l'intérêt des Français à l'intérêt des
industries européennes nous avons 8 pays
derrière nous nous avons une minorité de
blocages
la parole de